i've achieved my goal
this company is all mine
you lost your speed you're not much of a
threat are you
you just stay out of my way flash iris
is my wife
i have to save her what are you i am a
product of your broken mind
how much speed you have left not for a
few hours i need your help to build an
artificial speed force
that's how i can get my speed back i was
an empath too only i never held back
[Music]
imagine what you'd become if you weren't
so afraid
this time no one is coming to save you
now your friends
not your husband there's only two
options in this place
survival or madness
you lied yeah i lied oh frank
there's a supersonic jet about to crash
over the city and the flash isn't fast
enough to stop it eva can move anywhere
through any mirror in the universe in
the blink of an eye she's faster than i
am and somehow i'm supposed to stop her
i have unfinished business and a whole
world
to liberate we need a plan
we've all lost so much this year some
things can't be taken
we still have our will to fight for
those we love keep watching
keep trying to break me because i'm not
afraid of the woman that i am today but
you are eva
team flash needs as many hands on deck
as possible
we're not flash oh he goes save iris and
our friends
get everybody back
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my flash season 7
trailer video from dc fandom i'll break
it down there's a bunch of easter eggs
the showrunner was talking about doing
more crossovers with the justice league
movie characters like the ezra miller
crossover scene from crisis on infinite
earth's
there's a bunch of godspeed red death
stuff coming up so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
during the flash season 7.
i know everyone's just going to say put
grant gustin in the flash movie
let that be a moment that they also
acknowledge on the tv show
after he shows up in the movie because
there's so much stuff to cover here i'll
just number these as we go along to stay
organized as we talk about easter eggs
so
number 10 the footage at the beginning
is the rest of the plot from the
cancelled episodes from the end of
season 6
that would have ended the mere master
arc and set up the totally new
season seven plot the actual story for
season seven
but because of the virus you all
probably know that they had to stop
filming at the end of season six so
they're just a couple episodes that they
never got to and they're finishing those
for the first few episodes of season
seven so they're just wrapping up that
story line
hopefully they'll blow through it in the
first two maybe three episodes
then get to the actual season seven
storyline of reverse flash red death
more continuation on the justice league
earth prime stuff that they set up
during crisis on infinite earths and all
the new godspeed stuff
we also have a brand new superman in the
universe full time now because of the
superman tv show
and diggle green lantern that they set
up so number nine the mirror master
storyline was so incomplete that they
never really explained what her plans
were for the world what is her evil plan
usually that happens right after a
moment like this so i'm assuming that
we'll find out in episode one then
they'll wrap that up and fridge her
within the first couple of episodes and
move on to the next villain
i felt like she had a lot of potential
when they first introduced this version
of the character but now it's kind of
turned into a slog so i'm kind of hoping
that they blow through the rest of her
story arc
pretty quickly number eight iris still
stuck in the mirror dimension
originally she was supposed to get out
right before the season six finale
before they had to cancel that episode
so she'll probably bust out some time
with team flash's help maybe at the end
of episode 1 beginning of episode 2
pretty quickly yes it does seem like she
has some weird mirror master powers of
her own from being stuck in there for so
long
those probably won't work when she comes
out of the mirror dimension so when she
comes back out she'll be back to being
normal iris
while she still has them they'll
probably give her a fight scene with
mirror master
like remember the times that they gave
lois lane powers on smallville so that
she could go fight villains every once
in a while
just like that number seven the new
artificial speed force that they're
creating
it seems like they used chester p runk
to help finish the machine they used to
generate that
remember cisco went to atlantis for a
whole bunch of aquaman easter eggs to
get a special
perpetual motion device that only
existed in atlantis to complete that
machine
chester p runk will probably just help
them bring that science together
the thing about the new artificial speed
force though is that it's sort of this
meta thing that the show is using to
generate a bunch of brand new story arcs
that involves the brand new godspeed
storyline the new reverse flash
red death storyline other speedster
villains other villains who want to use
the speed force for themselves like
gorilla grodd
you give him a taste of that sweet speed
force honey he's going to want more
any time the flash says that they're
going to create an artificial source of
limitless dark matter energy what could
possibly go wrong
it means that everything that could go
wrong will go wrong
that's just how the tv show works that's
how comic books work they did the exact
same thing at the end of season one when
the particle accelerator went off
again caused a whole bunch of problems
and created a lot of the villains for
season two or
opportunities for the villains to
surface during season two number six
speaking of new team members
chester p runk and sue dibny are now
both series regulars on the show
originally i thought that chester was
going to replace cisco on the team
but they said that carlos the actor who
plays him is not supposed to leave the
show
but then they fired elongated man so now
i guess you could think of chester as
sort of a replacement for elongated man
on the team
he does have his own power set he can
create black holes which is pretty handy
they'll probably wind up using those to
defeat one of the villains sometime
earlier in the season
number five the sudibney storyline was
all about her clearing her name going
out doing more detective work with
elongated man because mirror master
framed her for the death of her husband
so they'll probably wrap that up when
they get rid of mirror master in the
first couple of episodes
but the way they said they're fixing the
problem with the elongated man's
storyline they have to find a way to
write him out of the show because they
got rid of the actor
is they said that they're actually going
to use his ability to change his face
to bring in another actor later then tie
that story line off but that's pretty
much the end of elongated man on the
show
number four the real godspeed will be
one of the major story arcs of season
seven they didn't say when
but it will be the real godspeed from
the comics finally not like the fake
ones or the velocity 9 speedster from
season 5.
they didn't say which actor would be
playing him but it will have something
to do with the new artificial speed
force barry created its limitless energy
limitless speed and godspeed said that
he was trying to steal
ultimate speed the last time he showed
up so once they get this new generator
under control
is probably when we'll start to see new
godspeed stuff
number three the new reverse flash in
red death i've done a couple videos
about this already but originally before
they had to cancel the season six finale
because of the virus
grant gustin said that they were going
to end the season on a huge reverse
flash wtf
twist and that would have been their
real season seven teaser with a setup
for the new major story arc
all of the evidence and all the episodes
they've been giving us this season with
the dragon ball style fusion speedsters
reverse flash taking over other people's
bodies like the gogeta flash
makes it seem like reverse flash will
take over someone else's body
and become the new red death from the
comics in the comics he's a speedster
fusion of batman and barry allen from
the dark multiverse but they can't
really use batman
that much on the flash tv show obviously
so that's why it would be someone else
that reverse flash would fuse with
number two justice league crossover in
the dc movies so the ezra miller flash
grant gustin crossover scene during
crisis on infinite earth's canonized all
the dceu movies to the arrowverse
during the dc fandom panel the
showrunner said that he planned on doing
more movie crossovers with the bigger
justice league actors
he named ray fisher's cyborg in
particular ray fisher seems like a total
dude willing to do them a solid he's
done a lot of tv shows in the past
couple of years he was just on an hbo
series
if ezra miller could show up for a day
to film a couple scenes
so could cyborg in cyborg will be in the
flash movie in a really big way
the flash movie will also reference the
grant gustin crossover scene
and during that scene ezra miller's
flash specifically name-dropped cyborg
saying that he had spoken to victor aka
victor stone about the existence of the
multiverse
the flash movie is just continuing that
theme when he does it again during the
movie
i've already done a video for the flash
movie teaser trailer so i'll link that
video at the end of this because they
also talk
about canonizing a lot of the other dc
movies from the past
30 years in that like a much bigger
version of what we saw during crisis on
infinite earths
the number one obviously grant gustin
cameo scene in the flash movie
the director of the flash movie didn't
give away any spoilers about that
but because the flash tv show runner is
so big on doing movie crossovers during
season seven and beyond he made it seem
like he'd be fine with grant gustin
taking a day or two off from filming the
show
next year to film a scene for the flash
movie when that gets going
it would either be just a really really
short cameo scene or they'd include
previous footage they rework
from the scenes they already filmed from
crisis on infinite earths
and just put that in the movie either
way thousand percent chance that he
shows up somewhere
in that flash movie as for next year's
dc tv crossover
originally said they were going to use
the new superman tv show as the core
of that and it would have been way fewer
characters it would have been a smaller
crossover than crisis
obviously they didn't say who the
villain was going to be or what the
story the crossover would be
but all the dc tv shows every single one
of them will not premiere until
january next year in 2021 but there will
be more trailers later this year
and there's going to be a second dc
fandom event
pretty early in september with a bunch
more tv stuff happening
so of course we'll do a video for
everything that they release there
everything they reveal hopefully they'll
give us some more details about the new
green lantern hbo series the justice
league dark hbo series
and any other really huge new things
that they're doing
everyone let me know in the comments
what you're most hyped up about
congratulations i like to draw
you're the giveaway winner for my last
big dc video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
everyone click here for that flash movie
teaser trailer
and click here to re-watch the batman
trailer with robert pattinson a billion
more times
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you